[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with Sonia Soda
Chief lead writer at The Observer and
Anita botang broadcaster and former
conservative special advisor lovely to
see you both so as ever let's take a
look shall we at the front pages
starting with the Metro the front page
there reporting on the prime minister's
pledge to clear the Asylum backlog
within a year
the telegraph also leads with sunax
migrant Crackdown as he promises to stop
those who got here by cheating
that story is also on the front of the
mail with a statement from the UK leader
saying he'll fix the appalling Asylum
fast
the eye leads with the pontins Revolt as
sunak faces the Tory backlash over plans
to house migrants in Holiday camps and
for the express they are leading with
can we have our country back please as
strikes have been paralyzing the UK
you've lost it Lynch takes the front of
the Sun as well strikes lead to
widespread disruption
the times shares its fears for cancer
patients and children as the UK's Chief
nurses tell Union Chiefs that key
Services could be in Jeopardy while the
mirror headlines nurses you're doing
we're doing this for you as Union Leader
Pat Collins so staff have been backed
into a corner the guardian features this
special report 33 hours inside an NHS on
the brink
the financial times carries a warning
from the bank of England alerting number
10 to the dangers of going too far in
their drive to deregulate the city
and border collie crush's car is on the
front of the Daily Star after a startled
dog jumped into the driver's seat
knocking the handbrake with a picture of
said dog in car anyway reminded by
scanning the QR code that you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
head to our guests then and uh Sonia and
Anita here
um well let's start with that statement
by Rishi sunak then Sonia shall we I'll
clear the Asylum backlog soonax my
migrant Crackdown what's changed and
will it work and and who wants it to
work
well I'm not sure very much has changed
really I think this is the third prime
minister in a row after Boris Johnson
and his trust to vow to clear the Asylum
backlog uh the government has always
focused very much on the numbers of
people crossing the channel a very
dangerous route uh along which some
Asylum Seekers have lost their lives
very tragically in recent months and
years
um but the really key thing I think is
the backlog here in the UK and that
actually doesn't have very much to do
with numbers coming across the channel
just to put those numbers in context
we're still having fewer people coming
to the UK to claim Asylum than at the
peak in the early 2000s we're having
um fewer claim asylum in the UK than in
France and Germany the head of
population for example there are lots of
European uh countries who have far more
Asylum claims per heads than the UK does
and the real reason that we've got a
backlog isn't the numbers coming up
across the channel it's because the
government has defunded the home office
bureaucracy and so decisions on Asylum
are taking far far longer to to be made
than they normally would be done and
we're talking about a system that's
really bad for people who are genuinely
fleeing War Terror conflict lots of our
refugees Asylum Seekers come from
countries like Iraq Afghanistan Syria
for example and most people's claims are
successful which shows that they are
genuinely people desperate people
seeking Asylum
so it's bad for them to be kept in limbo
for months often years in fact where
they can't work or they're living on a
pittance and it's also bad for the
system and bad for people in the UK so
really what the government's got to do
is get a grip on the system and fund the
home office bureaucracy better yes it's
solely the albanians which is a large
Focus also of this and
um you know some of the elements of his
five-point plan including housing uh
Asylum seekers in Holiday camps which is
the lead for the eye
um suggesting that one may be at an
active pontoon site in Southport and
merseyside and that sunlight faces an
outcry from his MPS over plans to house
Asylum seekers in pontins Holiday Parks
you know or elsewhere you know hotels
and everywhere being used currently I
know they're trying to get them out of
hotels
um what did you think of it Anita and
will it make any difference and I go
back to that question who wants this to
work why is this such a political issue
I kind of think everyone in the UK wants
a functioning Asylum system and there's
no doubt that everyone involved would
benefit from the system being much more
effective and efficient and by that I
mean processing happening much more
quickly and so one of the things I think
is really interesting about this sunak
is very much a details man and he has
been talking about how long and the
amount of effort and time that he's been
spending on this issue which makes me
think that him coming and saying that he
has his ambition for clearing that
backlog in the next year is something we
should take very very seriously and I
think will benefit Asylum claimant it
will benefit people in this country and
I think it will be fairer all round so I
think there really is something positive
to take from this because Russia sunak
is a prime minister who's interested in
kind of governing and and interested in
that detail and so the extra resources
that are going to go into making that
happen will be a positive now of course
the issue of where to house migrants
while we're dealing with that backlog is
going to continue to be fraught because
the public in general do not like the
idea of them being housed in fancy
hotels but of course if we're talking
about what CNAC has mentioned which is
using student accommodation using
Holiday Homes using
defense sites that means there's going
to be Asylum claimants all around in all
sorts of different places around the
country and I kind of think that
um it feels like the better option
certainly in terms of reducing the cost
of this system
and what do you think of this um
suggestion of having embedded British
officers in northern France embedding
them in Tirana in Albania Sonia as a
means of tackling those who are coming
here
well the government has said that it's
going to do this for months in terms of
France and the issue has always been
French don't want British officers on
French soil they want to give British
officers uh Powers because that
interferes with French sovereignty I
expect that we will see the same in
Albania the fact of the matter is
um that the the genuine difficulty is
that there are genuine victims of human
trafficking including women and children
who are coming to UK and other European
countries
um from Albania most of most albanians
who get referred about most people who
get referred to the home office scheme
for people who are victims of
trafficking on suspicion of trafficking
it's found that there's a lot of
evidence to substantiate the fact that
they are victims of human trafficking so
I think the government is looking to
sort of say well this is all the fault
of a country like Albania why why are
people coming here it's a sort of safe
country
that isn't the heart of the this issue
the heart of this issue is the fact that
government has been taking months and
often years to process people's asylums
claim which is good for no one and the
solutions that Rishi sunak is putting
forward they include for example trying
to make it illegal to come to the UK to
claim Asylum you know Boris Johnson has
suggested that Liz trusses suggested
that most expert lawyers think that that
would be the UK contravening
international law and it would be
subject to challenge it's also not the
right moral thing to do we've always
operated since the second world war a
refugee system you know as with the
country signed up to it so that when
somebody arrives in a country and puts
in an asylum claim their claim is Judge
on the merits of their claim not the
route through which they arrived which
you soon access people should only come
in through safe and legal routes well
there aren't very many safe and legal
routes so I'm afraid this is something
that's been put forward by Prime
Ministers before but I don't think it's
going to be implementable and I think it
is an example of Rishi sunac trying to
make it seem like previous conservative
Prime Ministers before him like he's
doing something that he probably isn't
going to be allowed to do when it comes
to international law
um to sort of just try and say something
like this in hand apologies for
interrupting you I just want to get
we've got what two other people on the
rail strike uh Anita
um lots of details about the rail track
not surprising for anybody who who
struggled to get into work or had an
office party that was canceled or
whatever it might be no end to the rail
strike misery it's Mick Grinch the Metro
tells us
um hitting the buffers trains going
nowhere this is an Ely in Cambridgeshire
and the Sun as well you've lost at Lynch
um you know the papers oh this paper I
suppose
um you know out to out to get him now
what do you think about public opinion
holding up for the for this strike and
the others
well it's really interesting that you
gov have been um the pollsters have been
tracking this story so yeah the two
stories you've mentioned one about no
end to Tyrell misery I'm sure
um most people that have tried to
commute or thought about commuting in
the next sort of week or so can attest
to that and then we've got the sun here
um you know giving it to Mick Lynch a
little bit because he's given these
rather testy interviews
um today in the morning round about the
rail strikes I think we had some
journalists um for instance um Michelle
Hussein on The Today program in my view
asking fairly reasonable questions about
the impact on rail workers themselves
um financially of striking and him
getting rather affronted at the idea
given even though it was something that
he had in fact introduced about the
sacrifice that rail workers were also
undertaking and what we're seeing from
you gov and and other pollsters who have
been tracking this for some time is that
the
um the support amongst the public has
been calling um somewhat um certainly
since the the strikes of the summer and
I think that obviously Christmas is a
really important time for for retailers
for our economy and for people wanting
to see loved ones and we've experienced
so many
um Christmases that have involved us not
being able to see as many loved ones so
I think this is being felt perfectly
apologies
um we've got so much to pack in I did
want to just show the sun again uh
they've got the Top Gear uh presenter
Freddie flintoff in a smash at the top
of their paper just to say there's been
a BBC statement now Freddie was injured
in an accident at the Top Gear test
track this morning with crew Medics
attending the scene immediately
um he's been taken to hospital we wish
him well that's all I wanted to say on
that so uh you know best of luck to her
to Freddie flintoff we're welcome back
you're watching the Press preview with
me once again Sonia Soda Chief leader
writer at The Observer and Anita botang
broadcaster and former conservative
special advisor welcome back to both of
you
um Daily Telegraph um let's go to that
Anita and this is the concern now about
Cancer Care cancer surgery in hospitals
at the time of the nurses strike which
is coming up later this week obviously
tell us more about this
yes this is um the story in the
telegraph that essentially there have
been concerns expressed that actually
urgent cancer surgery could be canceled
during this strike and that was a
warning from NHS England's cancer
director so this is all about the
pressure that the the NHS is going to
undergo as a result of the nurses strike
which is obviously the first one in
their history and it's going to be quite
a big and seismic moment and what we're
going to come back to in the course of
all these discussions is whether or not
the government should bring in these
minimum standards that means that for
critical areas like nursing which
obviously has a huge impact on the
Health Service we're going to end up in
a situation where they actually have to
deliver a certain number of nurses so
that some of the most acute and Urgent
matters can be taken care of like
there's something in this report saying
that actually in one place where you
can't get an appointment this this side
of Christmas because of the strike the
earliest you could be seen for a cancer
appointment would be the 9th of February
so quite a way away and lots to consider
yes and uh this is story broken by our
team at Westminster at Sky News but
let's go to the guardian which is you
know feeds into all of this
um a guardian Special Report 33 hours
inside an NHS on the brink which is
certainly uh the mood music we're
getting from the Health Service Sonia
absolutely so this is a special report
by two of my colleagues at the guardian
um looking at King's hospital and
looking at the emergency department and
one of the statistics it really stuck
out for me was that there's about 750
beds in Kings and when my two colleagues
were there the day you know they they
keep track of who might be discharged
that day not a single bed in the
hospital not a single patient was due to
be certainly be discharged that day
which shows really you know the hospital
should not be operating at this sort of
capacity I think the safe levels of
Hospital capacity around 85 and I mean
they've been exceeded for years the NHS
is under such pressure now that's as a
result of a decade of underfunding
um poor planning around Staffing and
lack of Staffing and of course the covid
pandemic and that's why we're seeing
waiting lists a record level but it's
really having a material impact on the
quality of care that's something they're
receiving it can't do that so this is
one of the reasons why nurses are saying
they're striking it's not just about
their pay it's something that there are
such big gaps that they feel that care
could become dangerous